tony we have a quote from you and it is
writing is about putting life on the
page it's about finding the amazing and
the mediocrity and the beautiful and the
sewers
it's important to get it on the page
and be a writer
can we talk about that quote sure that
sounds great i don't know when i said
that
okay
it sounds good all right yeah sure
um
i guess
probably at the time when i was when i
said that i was probably thinking of
just uh
getting life's messiness and the beauty
on uh
on the page um or on the screen
if we can um
because
i mean that's what i try to go that's
what i try to go for when i'm writing is
what's the heartache and then you know
what devastates me and then i'm like
okay now what's the levity uh what's the
um
where
where where can where can i find the
emotional breath in it where
because
just as i continue to write and live i
just find out oh wait everything is kind
of suffering and struggle but there's a
lot of joy in it and if if i'm
struggling then there's joy
so let's it's i guess for putting it on
the page
we condense it into a tincture
of um
our struggles and our joys because
when it's you know whether we're writing
a novel or a screenplay
the
um
it's so much more boring than our real
life our real life is very boring and
the screenplay is a condensed version of
it so
if we can just condense those
the beauty and the awfulness of just
being a human
and then just kind of move it around in
a lovely tragedy sad comedy way i think
that's maybe that's what i was trying to
get at i'm not sure
when you work with your students do you
notice they tend to lean one side or the
other in terms of some or more about the
mediocrity and the messiness and the
others are more about the beauty and you
have to find a middle ground
they most students have a hard time just
getting into conflict
um always
more
so
it's it's uh
especially beginning students or
students in the second quarter where
it's like
and i'm like this is cool but where's
this conflict and open
and and it's about finding you know when
the writing dialogue and i and i you
know i see what they're doing with their
characters i'm like oh this is sexy you
know i'm noticing something about this
character's relationship to the mother
what do you know the three-dimensional
character of the mother that she's
referring to because if you know that
then you'll know more about that
character and you don't need to say all
of it but you need to know it and that
will inform your
your dialogue it'll inform how your
character presents themselves in the
room it'll inform how the character
interacts with other characters
so um
so a lot of it is yeah push more
conflict and at the same time
just
write when you just write and and get
and you get the first uh
you get the first layer down
then then it's funny to start noticing
things where you're just like oh wait a
second that character might have a a
step brother who does blank and you
don't even need to
add that to the screenplay or to the
story but having that little bit of
backstory brings in another dimension of
the character
and it's sometimes um
when it gets to a director when it gets
to an actor they're feeling something
deeper because you put something deeper
in there so they can dig into something
deeper and i feel like that's when the
beauty happens and we don't tell each
other what the deeper was we let
everyone do their own deeper and then um
then they then yeah that's
that's where uh
so my student yeah as students as
students grow i think a lot of it is
just putting the time into writing and
the rewriting and put and just and then
they kind of start seeing the character
laid out and then when the characters
laid out oh wait a second it's funny how
i put that dialogue in i didn't even
notice at the time but
they may have a problem with blank and
explore that blank and then come back
and go does this work in here no but i
know that this person has a problem with
that and
kind of layer it in later in the story
interesting so let's suppose i'm going
to write something about a ceo
and
this ceo is very sort of
he has almost like a dictatorship
relationship with his employees but what
we don't know is his father used to to
run the company but we don't know that
as as the viewer as the reader
and his father was even more of sort of
a he had like a general uh that you know
ruled with an iron fist so if we knew
that as a writer but we don't have to
tell people it's kind of in our back
pocket
then then it might help with
how our main character interacts we know
that he has this history with his father
yeah and we can we can put subtle
breadcrumbs in there to write it that
way and when it gets to a director they
may see it the use i've noticed um
that they'll add their relationships and
their past to the stories so it might
not even be a father it could be an old
boss they used to work with and then so
they put a dynamic to that and then when
it gets to the actor the actor is like
okay how am i interpreting this on my
own what what does this mean to me
and so
they'll see how this character is acting
if they're acting like um
like they're a dictator uh they'll also
know that in their mind that that uh
that character believes that they're
doing the best they can for humanity
it's like they're the hero of their own
story even if they're awful people but
so it's like finding that balance of
where is the humanity because that
humanity's coming from somewhere so it
could come from abuse of a father it
could come from
so many different other things it could
come from where they grew up how they
grew up and they feel like what they're
doing is right to bring in the whole uh
to bring in whatever group they're
trying to bring in
and that's when um
that's when the beauty happens and
that's when we don't see we we
know it as screenwriters but then we
don't say it and then it's fun to see a
director go oh and then they just kind
of see them start to bring their own
stuff in they see the actor bring their
own stuff in and just don't ask any
questions just let them do their thing
that's that's when the great directors
and the great actors are just like they
pull it together so we got to do our
part on the page
and then
that it makes it it's uh it gives them a
huge opening
to explore in themselves
whatever part of the camera they're on
interesting right so so having so
knowing when to get out of the way of
your own work
and allow
the the actor and the directors to kind
of bring their own pieces to it oh
totally yeah and and when especially for
uh for jesus jerk i was a part of the
whole process so when i was on set every
day
and um and i just
i was fortunate i've taken acting
classes and i took classes on directing
you know like 20 years ago and then when
and then when all when all that came
together it's like everything came
together of oh okay i kind of knew what
to do and what not to do when i got on
set and it was just like
let it breathe and then
when uh when i felt like there needed to
be an adjustment i would never talk to
an actor i would talk to the i would
just pull the director aside really
quick and go hey and it had to be a it
had to be a major thing and i would just
like go this this and this and he'd be
like okay he turned around he goes you
know what let's try something else and
he would be taking my note but it
wouldn't be uh it's it's um
there's a beauty and finesse i guess to
uh
to letting people do their jobs and you
want to let people do their jobs because
they are good at their jobs you know
so with your students when it's a new
writer
and and you you want to bring out more
in them maybe maybe they're afraid of
putting in conflict maybe they've been
told oh let's only say nice things we
don't want to we don't want to be you
know a bad person or whatever
how do you how do you coax them
to not not do something overly salacious
where anyone's harmed but let's bring
some realism to it
i think that i think the conflict's
already there
sometimes i call it the agreeables so if
there's a if they send me two pages of a
scene and it's agreeable
um
then those characters can't agree with
the outcome but they can't agree to what
the outcome is how to get to the outcome
so they they their point of view needs
to be very um
needs to be almost like
uh what would you say maniacal because
their point of view is right on the page
to get to that outcome and they both
want to get to the same outcome
but um to get there there's got to be
friction
amongst themselves so
if if they're agreeable then i then
that's when i'm just like what's your
character's point of view on this
exactly why do they want to get there
what's behind there's okay what's behind
them what um
if you know if they're sisters what
conflict do they have
uh with uh being siblings if you know if
they're just best friends what conflict
do they have if they're cops in a buddy
movie great they're buddies but these
buddies are going to be at odds with
each other on how to get to
where they both want to go
you